I believe that the that the discussions
you've been having and the routing
around of the censorship industrial
complex that you've been forced to
engage in
we'll go down in history as some of the
most important
information
of our contemporary era I think that you
are engaged in what I like to call Holy
work a lot of people who I associate
with are like oh you know Brett
Weinstein like he's just it's like
the dead horse podcast it's like covered
covet and it's not you talk about more
but I actually think that this is super
important that we don't let it go and
most people are and you are not and so I
um I want to praise you for your bravery
your tenacity
you're open-mindedness and just your
work you and the whole team
um thank you that means a tremendous
amount to me and I I really appreciate
it there are elements of what you say
that I agree with let's take me out of
the equation I think it is vital that we
understand what happened during covid
and as I have said from the beginning it
wasn't about covid covid
revealed what was true of our system
having nothing to do with disease and it
revealed it across the board such that
if we could look at it and say how did
this happen and actually get to an
answer to that question we would know
what we had to do to fix it so that's
why I don't want to let it go right well
and I don't want you to let it go but
let me bring this around to a very
interesting convergence between rockets
and covet or sort of and that's the
following
um at NASA when you have a mission
failure
which does happen you know unfortunately
not all that often but you know we had
the Apollo 1 fire and the Apollo 13
mishap and the Challenger explosion and
the Columbia disintegration on reentry
and we've had a number of uncrewed
missions that have also failed the
Hubble Space Telescope
had a
issues when it was first deployed and
other things have not worked missions
have failed even if no humans were on
board when NASA has a mission failure
here's what they do
they convene a panel of experts who had
nothing to do with the project
they Empower that panel of experts to
have access to all documentation and all
Personnel who worked on the project and
they instruct the Personnel to be
completely honest and transparent
to the inquiries and these mishap
investigation boards or failure
investigation boards or accident
investigation boards they work
oftentimes for months or even a year and
you know what happens they almost always
figure out what went wrong and why it
went wrong and then they write up their
reports like the Challenger one with
Richard Feynman is quite famous they
write up their findings they don't just
it's not about blame it's about figuring
out what went wrong
documenting why it happened to and then
making recommendations to make sure it
never happens again
and so I always thought during covid
when things started to obviously get
weird and go off the rails and and you
know it was obvious the huge mistakes
were had been made I was like why don't
we convene if failure investigation
board or or maybe several because
there's so many different aspects
why do we get this wrong why do we get
that wrong why did we learn what do we
do and and I for a long time thought
this was the obvious answer and this is
what you know a competent government
agency would do but you know it it
didn't really happen
some individuals have tried to do it
um
RFK Jr comes to mind with his his book
letter to liberals but you know it's
just one man
um and now unfortunately I think
I'm not going to say it's too late but
maybe it's too late and too early at the
same time I think that the problem is
you can't find people who have nothing
to do with it to be on this committee
because everybody's polarized one way or
the other and their mind's made up you
know no I don't think that's why
actually that may be a component
but I think when when you consider what
NASA is
the chances that somebody has an
interest
in Mission failure
or very low right your enemies might but
the chances that they're gonna get into
NASA and they're going to cause Rockets
to blow up what otherwise succeed that
you know I'm not saying it will never
happen but that has not been the answer
to what has happened yet and what that
means is that although certainly you
know there have been embarrassing errors
we've uh had Mission failures because of
unit conversion errors yeah Imperial
versus metric units
but aside from covering your ass when
you've made an error or you've you know
you've you've made the call that the
space shuttle will launch in spite of
temperatures to which the O-rings aren't
tolerant has happened in the Challenger
disaster so there is a cover your ass
Instinct but there is not a
nobody sells out the public
to hijack a NASA mission for other
purposes and therefore the covering your
ass is of a normal human scale
yeah I don't want to bash on NASA but I
want to push back just a little bit I
basically agree with what you said and
and and uh I think you're right that
that's a possibly substantial uh
Divergence between covid Mission failure
and mass emission failure but it is but
look there is a certain amount of
capture even within NASA like there's
companies that you know are on the gravy
train and they want to keep building
these expensive systems so like it shows
up in less dramatic ways but like maybe
they're not interested in building more
efficient systems or you know you know
it's a standard kind of Defense
Contractor mentality it's SpaceX has
disrupted that to some extent but uh
it's there so but but it's a smaller
it's a less it's Insidious but far less
uh
deadly form of uh capture than we saw
arguably in the coven and in Food and
Health in general
well I also think
that the
there's a question of how Divergent the
incentives are
it used to be that one expected Pharma
for example to push its profitable drugs
and to drive out
previous drugs that had lost their
patent you expected a certain amount of
that
and you didn't necessarily expect them
to push a drug that would actually harm
patients you just thought there was some
sort of shell game about which
prescription you were going to get you
might get a drug that was 20 less
effective because it was under patent
but you weren't expecting a toxin
and I believe this is maybe I've just
woken up to it but I believe this has
gotten
this has changed over time and that now
you actually have an industry in the
case of Pharma where
you know what is demand called
with respect to Pharma products
ill health so you have an industry that
wants demand which means it wants ill
health and it has woken up to how to
create that demand and then fill it with
the supply of something that may or may
not be efficacious by
creating the impression that something
is efficacious
but put that aside in the NASA context
even if you've got a contractor who
wants you to put something that they
make on your rocket and it's less
efficient than some competing thing that
you might source that would be better
for the mission right it's still not
antagonistic to the mission
and so if it became antagonistic to the
mission then I think your argument about
why NASA failures are
uh frequently understood in their
aftermath
would fail it would break down but for
the moment as long as everybody has an
interest in figuring out what went wrong
so it doesn't happen next time you can
have a proper investigation and the
punch line to that is
in the case of covid you have people
with the power to succeed actively
obstructing our comprehension of what
just happened YouTube's not like
offering to to uh reinstate
you and and your kind of am I correct
that you're still feeling um well it's
very interesting what's happened at
YouTube and I the pattern again is
absolutely conspicuous from my chair
let me describe it to you
we
went far enough that they felt that they
could get away with demonetizing the
channel and I believe that their plan
was to kick us off the platform
they we had two channels we had 400 plus
thousand subscribers on each a main
channel on Eclipse Channel and
frankly
we were making money in a way that was
new to us
it lasted for one month
we did a live I did a live discussion
with Pierre Corey about in question and
then I did a live podcast with Steve
Kirsch and Robert Malone I remember it
and they pulled both of those things
they struck the channel they set up the
conditions to remove us I believe they
would have accepted it if we had
self-censored they would have backed off
and they would have restored our ability
to earn that's I think what they wanted
but failing that they were perfectly
ready to throw us off and then Joe Rogan
through what he uh declared an emergency
podcast he held at an emergency podcast
about the situation and it resulted in
YouTube backing off entirely
the
the channel remains it is unmonetized
YouTube refuses to remonetize it but
conspicuously
the audience is completely static it was
absolutely skyrocketing before they
demonetized us and then it just it was
going up up up plateau and it's been
into Plateau ever since
so what that tells me is that they're
interfering that they have they zeroed
out more than half our family's income
and but here's the other part of the
pattern
we can say whatever we want
they don't strike the channel
so I think the point is you can say
whatever you want but but you think that
do you think people are actively like
how can I say this
are they actively not able to access
your videos or is it just that you're
for whatever reason your subscriber
counts the the Beast decides who sees
what it decides what to suggest when it
decides who to unsubscribe we don't know
the full rain it decides what to tell us
about who's watching it could be that
more people are seeing it than we know
but the numbers are artificially flat it
could be that it's being kept from
people it could be that there's a target
number that are allowed to see it people
who have already been lost whatever so I
don't know what the pattern is but the
idea that we derailed a plan to get rid
of us by creating pain Joe Rogan created
pain it wasn't worth it to Google to
admit what they were doing as they would
have had to if they threw us off and so
they backed off their overt plan they
block our reach or our ability you know
the fact is the number of subscribers to
the channel dictates what it is that we
can earn if we've source an Advertiser
from outside of that ecosystem the
question is well how many people can you
reach so that number is directly
interfering with our ability to earn
it's interesting thing you described
with YouTube is an example of Scramble
for the middle
yes well
um it is an intermediate solution I know
because insiders at Google have told me
that the decision about what to do with
our channel the decision not to
remonetize it was made in the c-suite
quite possibly by the CEO but certainly
in the c-suite so it was a top level
concern
and I think the other thing that people
perhaps don't quite understand is
this is a big Channel
but it's not a gigantic one so when I
say that we're being interfered with at
this level it sounds like a delusion of
grandeur on the other hand if you think
about what it is that actually happened
to the covet narrative
well who showed up on Dark Horse and
then went to Joe Rogan
right we had Pierre Corey we had Robert
Malone we had Peter McCullough so that
was uh
Darkhorse violated a sacred rule you
can't have two PhD biologists saying
actually this is complex but it's not as
complex as you think it is this is more
comprehensible than you know let's
unpack it let's talk about what the
actual facts of the disease are what the
actual facts of the therapy are what the
evidence really suggests where the
evidence seems to be phony
so we did that
and we talked to people who had been
targeted for dismissal
you on-ramped them onto Rogan who
couldn't be dismissed right now I I
don't I don't want to underrate what Joe
was doing yes Joe was paying attention
to Dark Horse and he listened to the
discussions with these folks but Joe is
an incredibly smart guy and very widely
read and he has an excellent
detector
he knew that this story wasn't making
sense and he knew what sense sounded
like sounds like Pierre Corey it sounds
like Robert Malone and when you look
into these people's backgrounds and you
hear they're supposed to be quacks and
then it turns out actually these are Top
Flight people in their fields with
impeccable credentials so I think the
point was you can't
the role that Dark Horse played in this
story was in its own way yeah maybe
on-ramp is is the right descriptor it's
a good one but the point is oh if we can
do away with the on-ramp yeah that
solves a big problem and I believe that
they've decided to do away with the
on-ramp and you know we've I'm not
complaining about the quality of my life
I live wonderfully but
the interference with our family's
ability to earn the interference with my
ability to produce security from my
children in light of a very dangerous
world that's being made Dangerous by the
very people who are doing the
interfering is absolutely maddening it's
maddening I agree I find it maddening
and I'm not even you know
running any sort of media
um
company or whatever we want to call it
entrepreneur maybe the entrepreneur
thing um this tells me I should have
gone into rocket science
oh I don't know about that I could I
would you know I I'm not going to go
into my personal
um
battles over all this stuff
let's just put it this way I was within
one day of being fired for being an
unvaccinated person who worked at a U.S
company with over 100 employees and then
the Supreme Court stepped in and said I
don't know
so you know
um that's as much as I'll say about it
um and so and then you'll and to be you
know to be fair or like it's I can't
blame my company for this like this was
the law supposedly like they had to fire
me you know and um what are they going
to do close the company like a thousand
people because like three or four you
know contrarians no of course not and so
anyway it didn't happen thank goodness
for uh
the
um Constitution
thank goodness for the Constitution
although
among the many
jaw-dropping facts of covid are the
number of people who could not find that
constitutional protection could not find
protection under Healthcare code right
healthcare workers right health care
workers members of the military
and that you know I get stopped fairly
regularly
by people they with literally two
exceptions since Evergreen happened what
they say what people say in person is
always nice oh
um and something that I have been
hearing a lot in the last year is
thank you I did not get vaccinated
because you and Heather were making so
much sense on this topic and it gave me
the courage to resist
and every time I hear this I
I feel this powerful sense of having
done something right
to well the the the the danger of the
shots was so great that the idea that
there are people walking around out
there
who don't have to worry about the damage
that they did because we made sense to
them I don't know I did I'm I'm
heartened by it that's why I said and I
think it's only just begun when I say
that history will will in my estimation
uh remember you well I don't mean the
history of the next couple years what I
mean is that once there are
dispassionate once people once this is
like
history and not present and I know
that's a loaded
term because who knows what road we're
headed down with the inevitability of
future pandemics and all the other
crises that are being um promoted but uh
you know in the
eventually there will be Scholars who
will be mining all this stuff
and you know obscure videos on like
former platforms that no longer exist
it's going to be like historical gold
and and I think I think
the truth will prevail
[Music]
foreign